- [Voiceover] So let's say
that we have the equation
negative seven x minus eight y
is equal to 28.
So this right over here,
this is a linear equation,
it's in standard form,
and what I want to do
with you in this video
is I want to rewrite this
in slope-intercept form.
And so, just as a reminder,
this right over here is standard form
and I want to convert it
to slope-intercept form,
which has the form of y is
equal to the slope times x
plus the y-coordinate of the y-intercept.
So let's see how we do this.
It's just gonna take a little
bit of algebraic manipulation
and, like always, I encourage
you to pause the video
and try to work through it
on your own before I do it.
So what we really wanna do is we just
wanna isolate the y here
on the left hand side
so I wanna get rid of
this negative seven x
and the best way to get
rid of a negative seven x
is to add seven x, so I'd wanna
add seven x to the left hand side
but in order to maintain this equality,
I've gotta do it to both sides.
So let's add seven x to both sides
and then I'm going to be left with,
on the left hand side,
negative seven x plus seven x,
those cancel out, so
I get negative eight y
is equal to seven x plus 28.
And now, I just want a y out here,
so I wanna get rid of this
negative eight coefficient
and the best way to do that
is divide both sides by negative eight.
So divide both sides by negative eight
and what are we left with?
On the left hand side,
you're left with just y,
that's why we divided by negative eight,
y is equal to seven
divided by negative eight,
that's negative 7/8 x,
and then eight divided by negative eight
is negative one, minus one.
And just like that we have written it
in slope-intercept form.
We rewrite it in this form, it
immediately jumps out at us,
that the slope here is negative 7/8,
or the slope of the line
that would represent
all of the solutions to
this linear equation,
all the x,y pairs that satisfy it,
and the y-intercept, if we
were to graph that point,
the coordinates of that point would be
zero comma negative one.
That's the value of this
form right over here,
slope-intercept form.